hello everyone and welcome back to the
finals of the world Fisher random
championship is the game for Magnus
Carlsen now with the white pieces still
against Wesley Sol and Magnus Carlsen in
a very difficult spot he's down
well he's not down two points he's down
two games because at one classical game
here is worth three points so he's down
six points and he really needs to win
this one at to maybe catch up tomorrow
in the rapid section of the match so
before checking out this game and it's
really a wild game now I would just like
to mention that there is a giveaway and
that's a few maybe a week or two weeks
ago we discussed a music video by by
hygge actually made a chest song about
mikhail tal now she's doing the giveaway
on chess calm you can win a Premium
Membership you have to test your
knowledge on Mikhail tal and you have to
find eight hidden references the Mikoto
in her song so four of the references
are in the music video in the video
itself and four of the references are in
the lyrics of the song so I will put a
link to the first song and the YouTube
video in the description below it will
be the first thing you see and the
second link will be a link to the shell
calm article where you can apply if you
want to win a their diamond membership
so if that's your thing if you want to
test out your knowledge and make out
I'll give it a go now that being said
let's get back to the game Game four of
the first official World facial random
championship finals Magnus Carlsen with
the white pieces opens with a four very
very exciting stuff we have E 5 by
Wesley he give this position of thought
as of course they after Game one they
checked the the position with the engine
and from the start II for nd for I
believe were the best moves but a for
maybe ancients third recommendation or
something like that but definitely
interesting as Carlsen down two games so
he has to get back in the match Wesley
replies in a principled matter he goes
for the center he plays d5 and here
Carlson goes a5 he wants to create some
very early weaknesses on the Queen side
by pushing the pawn all the way to a a6
Wesley says ok if you don't want the
center I'm just gonna grab the center
those principles apply even though this
is special random and Magnus goes for a
six so we reach the position from the
thumbnail and Whistler of course goes B
six he doesn't want to open up the
position and we have D three by Magnus
now with Knight to d6 by Wesley and now
after giving the position some thought I
don't think this is something Magnus
prepared before the game because he
spent a few minutes here he played efore
it's basically a pawn sacrifice and he
says okay if you want to grab the pawn
then maybe we can get some sort of a
wild position where I can maybe get back
into the match so Wesley after giving
the position some thought he decided to
capture it he says okay I can grab this
pawn he played D captures a need for D
characters and the knight captures on e4
and what was Magnus idea Quinta e - is
what Magnus plays she wants to like
Queenie to f3 and win back the e5 pawn
ideas like Bishop f3 seem like a better
idea but they don't work because you
you're not gonna go Bishop c6 and allow
Queen c4 black and just play f5 and it's
just it's just a fine position for black
and also f5 is very important you don't
want to allow this Queen to get the e4
square at any time to have some Queen b7
ideas so after Knight tappers any for
Queen e2 by Magnus and now f5 just
defending the knight also keeping an eye
on the e4 square f3 and mountain I'd
back to d6 not f6 of course you want to
be f6 available for this night and on
the other hand it covers the be 5
squared whereas this Bishop can be
nicely developed over to b5
Magnus recaptures the point and now
Bishop to f6 just continuing development
with Queen to f4 and here Wesley could
go for g5 seems like I seems like a nice
idea as the principles still work in
official random you don't want to bring
your queen out too early if Queen before
then you can even continue harassing the
queen with c5 but okay Wesley decides
that safety first he decides to Castle
queenside and now comes Knight G - E -
and here Wesley plays g5 finally you can
see that Carlson has only the Queen out
and the knight is in a very well weird
spot
not really sure where the night is going
it's impossible to develop the light
square bishop for the moment and it's a
really ugly position for white to be in
magnus place Queen to e3 and here feel
free to pause the video and try to find
the best move for Wesley in this
position while I give you a couple of
seconds so for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations it's a
beautiful tactical idea and for those of
you who just want to enjoy the show and
we even have let me just check if I
prepared it yeah I have this is the
moment Wesley this is the well for of
Wesley when he was considering what to
do here so you can see that he's eyeing
that beat upon which I'm sure you were
all eyeing so here Wesley played Bishop
capture son be - so now you of course
realized that the knight is controlling
to see Foursquare if King captures just
Knight c4 check wins the Queen is the
game over for Magnus and on the other
hand after Bishop captures on b2 if you
try Queen to East six check Bishop d7
and twenty five hoping for Queen to a8
mate then just c6 now the Queen has to
go away and then just Bishop captures
rook so here
Magnus of course saw a bunch of
character send me - he immediately
played Bishop the c3 here Magnus is now
hoping for better person a 1 followed by
Bishop captures on a 1 threatening in
the rook and maybe Wesley could go wrong
it Wesley has to go in tonight at 6 or
97 here give up the exchange back
because if he tries Knight to f6 to
defend it
then Queen e5 will be just excellent for
white now there is no way to defend the
night here and if you move the knight
then you lose a whole rook so Wesley
doesn't get carried away he plays the
simple brush of character son c3 we have
Knight captures on c3 and now again
Wesley could go for f4 it is it is one
of the possibilities after the Queen
moves continue developing Knights to e7
go Knight to c6 and the White Queen will
have very little squares that that will
be useful to her but Wesley continues
with Queen to f6 first ties the Queen to
the defense of the night here and now
prepares to develop his other pieces and
here Magnus could go for Knight to d5 it
seems like
a possibility but that's were the Wesley
also had in mind when he played Queen to
have six now tonight the c-4 is very
strong threatening the Queen threatening
Queen to be to checkmate
so here Magnus would have no other
choice other than to trade Queens
captures captures here we would have
captures sorry captures your characters
here and Magnus would have to play this
position where he is down a pawn and the
a6 pawn is definitely a liability rook
to e6 will come at some point be five
then the rook will attack the a6 pawn
the knight will join in the action it
should be fairly simple to pick it up so
after Queen to f6 Magnus goes for H for
yet another will alpha zero move
creating more complications and now
Wesley Wesley to move Wesley decides for
he could go for G captures on h4 right
away but he says I don't need to grab
any more pawns he plays Knight to c4
right away just attacking the Queen here
and also there are some tricky lines
where maybe if if the Queen can get over
to b4 it could get very dangerous for
white so here Magnus plays each
character son g5 you cannot go Queen
captures because just Queen captures and
c3 the Queen still has to guard the
knight on c3 so H garrison g5 with
Knight captures on e Knight captures on
e3g captures on f6 so we have a queen
trade Knight captures on f6 and now
Knight the d3 continuing development and
here rook to g8 or Wesley it doesn't
want to pick up the pawn right away he
says I'm gonna develop first it's not
like you can save the pawn as it is
attacked twice and here
what's Magnus got for his well
suspicious played out of the opening is
that he's up ten minutes on the clock
but still you know it's it's move move
in 1903 Qing move or the players are
granted additional time so it is a small
bonus but still you are down upon and
well you have a worse position with
Bishop to e2 by Magnus and now Wesley
picks up yet another pawn so Wesley now
up two pawns and here we have Knights to
f4 pushing Wesley's route back route
back to g8
and now Bishop to d3 pressuring the f5
pawn if denied from e3 move
we have looked these for now by wesley
going after the Knighton here on f4 and
now night c2e2 attacking the rug
defending the night route back to d6 by
Wesley and now came to be to preparing
to bring the other rook into the game
here the situation on the clock Magnus
30 minutes Wesley 15 minutes and here
Wesley wants to develop the lights for a
bishop but he first pushes c5 he doesn't
want to close his own sheep on with his
bishop so first the c5 also has ideas of
pushing c4 and the Magnus plays rook 81
sort of expecting c-4 preparing a
discovery against this night on e3 but
Wesley calculates precisely he pushes c4
and here Magnus has to go for Knight to
c3 there is no other move so he offers a
trade here and Wesley except C captures
on d3 will look out for Sonny 3d
captures on c2 now and Magnus has to
decide where he wants to capture right
away rook to e7 seems like an idea going
after the a so important but then there
should be seven not you you're not you
don't have any better I moved in just
capturing the c2 point so here if Magnus
goes to look back to see one he wants
the at least gain some activity for his
sacrifice pawns Wesley says okay King b8
I don't want my king and the C file
Magnus captures the pawn and now Bishop
to d7 just adding another defender here
to the 305 pawn the rook can now come
over to c8 at some point you are
preparing to pull b5 the bishop covers
the b v square you hope to pick up the
a6 bonus well so rook to e7 by magnus
and now it's a well it's a not a
critical moment or anything but it's a
very important moment for both of them
and here the situation on the clock is
23 minutes Magnus 13 minutes Wesley
whereas the situation on the heart rate
monitor is 85 heartbeat a Magnus whereas
Wesley is at 144 so definitely feeling
the pressure and here he just continues
b5 he says I'm just gonna win the a6
pawn and there is no way to defend it so
Magnus goes rook to f7 now hoping to
create some complications but with
I'm not interested in any of your
complications he plays the root
characters on a6 and now Magnus was onto
something but he didn't find it he
probably he was playing on West this
time he had the rope to d2 here
threatening some ideas like Luke captors
here just removing the defender of the
bishop and then you have to go Bush up
to c8 which removes the defender of the
b5 one so here after Knight captures
rook to b6 now you move the king and if
fruit crates rook captures and f6 at
least you've grabbed one of the pawns
but Magnus goes for Knight the d5
instead with Knight captures on d5 and
now Knight captures on d5
just to show rogue captures here Knight
chapters and rook here poses no threat
for Wesley as the rook here guards the
a7 point so you can give one check but
it's meaningless you're not gonna gain
any country play for your sacrifice
piece so Knight captures on d5 and here
we have worked d6 defending defending
the bishop and also attacking the knight
here so Knight the e7 by Magnus also in
a very interesting line is Knight to f6
attacking the rook and the double attack
on the disappear but then Bishop to e6
is just a very very complicated
for example rook after Sun h7 now you go
roof to g6 you attack the knight Knight
has to go back Knights - I ate and now
rook to d8 again you attack the knight
rook to e7 you defend the night and now
Bishop to c4 you just block off this
roofs advance to c7 and this Knight now
has no squares all the squares are
covered by by blacks pieces and you will
not be enjoying yourself is just a very
passive position here so it is possible
but you're down material you don't want
to be down material and in a passive
position so here Knights the e7 instead
by Magnus and now comes rook to e8
witnesses okay I mean I'm up three
points I'm just gonna push my H pawn
there it seems pretty straightforward
Magnus goes rook to c5 puts pressure on
the f5 pawn here and Wesley just plays
a6 it's a very useful move now the
bishop no longer has to keep an eye on
the b5 pawn Knight captures an f5 now
grabs one of the points but now Wesley
trades Bishop captures with Brooksie
captures an f5 and now the situation on
the clock is 17 minutes Magnus seven
minutes Wesley but he pushes h5 he has
to make four more moves there each time
control and it's not that the position
is all too complicated those four moves
are fairly straightforward so here
Magnus has to figure something out he
plays rook the e5 he hopes to get some
perpetual ideas here to maybe go for a
draw but Wesley calculates precisely h4
we have rook to e7
and now just rook to be sex not even
allowing rook to b7 check to Magnus we
have King to c3 magnets now brings the
King into the game but now h3 Magnus now
has to trade one of the rooks it's ugly
but you have to do it rook captures with
rook captures on h7 and now rook to f6
Wesley now forces Magnus to go into a
very passive position with the rook we
have rook captures on h3 and now King
Tubby 7 Wesley starts bringing the King
into the game and soon he will start
pushing his two connected passports on
the Queen side came to d4 by Magnus and
now kink the b6 with King D 5 attacking
the rook rook to f8 and now f4 so Magnus
starts pushing his past F pawn but one
past F pawn is nothing compared to do
past and be pawns will be 4 by Wesley
and now f5 with a 5 by Wesley and now
rook to f3
Magnus puts the rook behind the past
pawn but now a 4 we've came to d4 by
Magnus now king b5 and here came to d3
and here well you could make a mistake
it's not it's not like it's a completely
harmless position if you play something
like a3 then King c2 will draw the game
for white if you allow King b3 for white
for example if King to a4 then then
f6 rook the c8 check your gonna go King
to be 1 and now after b3
just ripped f4 check you put the black
King back and now look the f5 check King
to c4 and now you'll push f7 and this is
enough for White's to have a draw
because well you're just the threatening
to bring a queen into the game and if
rook to a fate then just rope there
three you cut off the black king from
deeper into the position so here Wesley
could make a mistake but Wesley did not
reach the finals of the world Fisher
random championship by making mistakes
in well sort of a simple rook and game
for player of his caliber so he goes
rook to c8 he cuts off the White King
from reaching any of any of these
squares so f6 by Magnus and here Wesley
played b3 and after considering what to
do for a few minutes it was in this
position I move fifty that magnus
carlsen resigned the game he resigned
because there is nothing to do here for
example once you push f7 let's say it
doesn't really work b2 and now although
you get a queen in the game black gets a
queen with check so once the King moves
let's say King anywhere just pick up the
Queen it's the simplest way it's it's a
queen against the rule completely
winning and if you don't push f7 for
example if you try some - some checks
working five checking before rook check
here King here again just B to be one
win the game if you push then again b1
check b1 promotes a width check so yeah
really incredible stuff after b3 Wesley
wins third game in a row against Magnus
which is something I don't think anyone
ever did in a match against or maybe not
even in a match like whoever won three
games in a row against Magnus it's I
don't think that ever happened before
and it's something that Magnus might not
be able to cope with as he never faced
it before you know it's you have to
learn how to deal with a loss if if
you've never experienced such a loss how
could you possibly learn such you know
such a skill and after losing the second
game in a row you can see that Magnus
went all out in this game but it just
wasn't enough it was a sort of sort of
tilted and it did not work out for him
Wesley just played normal moves
principled moves and well at the end of
the day really really good moves and it
was more than enough to win this game so
really exciting stuff we're gonna see I
with winning three games now that's
three but that's nine points for Wesley
and drawing the first game that's ten
and a half
and he needs 12 and a half points for a
win in the match so if Wesley wins only
one game tomorrow or I believe if he
draws two games then then he wins the
match we will not be seeing the Blitz
section so if Magnus wants if Magnus
really wants his favorite random World
Championship title he's gonna I don't
know he's gonna have to go super saiyan
tomorrow and like win four games in a
row
to be able to even reach the doublet
section of of the match but with the way
Wesley is playing it is very very
unlikely but and then again Magnus is
not where he is by not being able to
perform miracles so tomorrow there
should be extremely interesting but yeah
that's that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed it Magnus most definitely did
not I would like to thank Rossi Nepal
Geoff grace and for mask imil for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot - really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous videos here
think'll for watching and I will see you
soon
continuing the coverage of the world
fish render Championship which might not
go for all that long continuing the
coverage of the European Team
Championship and of course checking up
on your wonderful suggestions so thank
you all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day